the story of Cesar Millan is often seen
as a typical rags to riches tale about a
young man from Mexico crossing the
border in pursuit of the American dream
while that's more or less how things
happened the reality of Milan's eventful
life is a little more complicated
while Milan became known to millions of
viewers worldwide as the dog whisperer
his off-camera life has been anything
but quiet he was bullied for his love of
dogs Milan grew up on his grandfather's
farm in Sinaloa in northwestern Mexico
during this time he became accustomed to
working with a variety of animals though
he claims to have had a natural way with
dogs from a very young age this
connection with canines was so strong
that Milan found himself being followed
by dogs every time he left his home a
fact that didn't go unnoticed by the
other kids
he was constantly teased by his peers
who started calling him el perro which
according to Milan roughly translates to
the dirty dog boy
Milan refused to let bullying change his
mind about his love of dogs instead he
concentrated on making his dream a
reality from a young age by the time he
was 13 years old he had laid out plans
to become the best dog trainer in the
world and he decided that the best place
to begin his takeover was the US
inspired by the immaculately well
trained performing dogs he saw in TV
reruns of lassie in The Adventures of
Rin Tin Tin Millan set his sights on
Hollywood convinced his talents would be
most welcome there he entered the US
illegally in 1991 Milan made his way
from his home to a Tijuana bus station
with $100 to his name seeking
transportation across the border when he
finally found a way out of Mexico via a
hole in the border fence he was forced
to pay $100 every cent he had in order
to pass through Milan entered the United
States with no money no friends little
to no knowledge of the English language
and nowhere to live
he spent his early days in America
living homeless on the streets of San
Diego sleeping under a freeway and
surviving on nothing but convenience
store hot dogs
Milan recalled that he could get two
hotdogs for 99 cents at the time meaning
all he had to do to survive was somehow
make a dollar a day many hotdogs later
he managed to land his first real job
stateside he found work as a dog groomer
using the first english sentence he ever
learned
I learned to say do you have application
for work that was the first sentence I'm
gonna learn Milan managed to arrange
some part-time hours in a local dog
groomers office the owners were
instantly impressed with his assertive
handling of larger aggressive dogs that
had previously been impossible to
control
Milan saw the value in this and after
moving to Englewood decided to start
charging for a group dog walking service
he quickly attracted attention with his
unusual and very much illegal style of
walking his group off leash quickly
earning a reputation as the Mexican guy
who can walk a pack of dogs some of his
first clients were Will and Jada
pinkett-smith who paid for Milan to have
a year of English language lessons his
reputation grew quickly Milan and his
dog walking business spread like
wildfire by word of mouth and he
eventually earned enough money to open
his dog psychology center in South
Central Los Angeles his success at
rehabilitating dogs with particularly
troublesome paths led to him being
profiled in a 2002 edition of the LA
Times and the reaction was huge the
story led a string of producers to his
door hoping to create a new TV show
highlighting Milan's techniques and the
trainer signed on to front Dog Whisperer
with Cesar Millan soon after the
National Geographic Channel ended up
picking up the show for 26 episodes
after Animal Planet refused to commit
beyond a pilot he's been involved in a
number of lawsuits things weren't all
sunshine and rainbows for Milan however
the dog whisperer star was the subject
of two lawsuits in a single week in 2006
the first involving his former publicist
Makita Smith and her partner foster
quarter the couple claims that they had
come up with the name dog whisperer
while in discussion with Milan after
they received no recognition of their
contribution they decided to sue the
National Geographic Channel asking for
five million dollars in damages Milan
was in hot water again days later when
eight Simple Rules producer floatie
Suarez claimed that his five year old
Labrador Retriever Gator was subjected
to inhumane treatment at the celebrity
trainers facility Suarez's lawsuit
stated the Gator was covered with
bruises and gasping for breath after
being forced to run on a treadmill the
producer went on to describe how a choke
chain had caused damage to Gators
esophagus and that surgery was needed to
correct it with the vets bills totaling
more than $25,000
he has been accused of animal cruelty
Cesar Millan aka The Dog Whisperer is
under fire for of all things animal
cruelty the incident with Gator the
Labrador is not the only allegation of
animal cruelty Milan has faced American
Humane the oldest national organization
specializing in the protection of
animals revealed they had sent a letter
to the National Geographic Channel in
2006 the letter in question expressed
outrage about the inhumane and
potentially harmful tactics employed on
Dog Whisperer with Cesar Millan other
critics of Milan's methods include
certified animal behavior consultant and
pet journalist Steve Dale who refers to
Milan as the dog screamer along with
British television personality Alan
Titchmarsh who berated Milan over his
barbaric techniques during an interview
on his afternoon TV show he hit hard
times in 2010 2010 was a terrible year
for Milan starting off in the worst
possible way when his sidekick daddy
died of cancer at the age of 16 he held
me for 16 years and I don't think that I
did much for him as much as he did for
me the gentle giant whom he'd adopted
from rapper Redman was not just Milan's
assistant on the show he was his best
friend off camera
sadly Milan barely had time to mourn the
loss when he was hit with more bad news
the following month his wife of 16 years
informed him she had filed for divorce
Milan was forced to assess his finances
and that was when the third blow came he
soon realized that despite being one of
the most recognizable TV personalities
in America he made a series of bad
business decisions that had left him
with little to show for his nationwide
fame he tried to end it all in 2012
Milan opened up about the full extent of
what he'd gone through two years earlier
he claimed he'd lost his source of
calmness when his beloved dog daddy died
and the added pressure of his divorce
and financial woes sent him into a
downward spiral of depression the famous
trainer got to the point where he didn't
want to be alive anymore taking what he
described as a whole bunch of pills and
hoping not to wake up
fortunately for Milan his sons
discovered him before it was too late
and he was rushed to the hospital he
later talked about how regaining
consciousness and award full of patients
who loved his show helped him to get
back on track with his life he used his
own methods to bounce back Milan was
offered antidepressants after
failed to take his own life though he
decided that the best way to heal was to
practice what he preached in place of
pills Millan devised a rehabilitation
schedule based on his knowledge of pack
life using exercise discipline and
affection to conquer his depression and
it seems to have worked wonders his path
led him to new partner Yahaira dar whom
Elan credits is being instrumental in
his recovery along with a series of new
opportunities in television he was soon
back on small screens everywhere in
Cesar Millan's the leader of the pack
and Cesar 911
he's even branched out to younger
audiences working alongside his son
Calvin in Nickelodeon's live-action
series mutt & stuff thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]